Football coaches wear clothes bearing their
team’s logo thanks to the NFL’s push to
sell more merchandise.
Basketball coaches stand on the sideline in
collared shirts and blazers looking for a
neat, professional look.
And then there are baseball managers who dress
in the team uniform, as if they are planning
on joining their players on the baseball diamond.
Despite that today’s managers are universally
beyond the point where they could play at
a level worthy of putting them in the field,
the tradition of them wearing the team uniform
dates back to a time when that’s exactly
what they did.
Specifically, the position that managers hold
today used to be typically held by the team
captain.
This person was a player responsible for making
decisions about plays on the field during
the game.
He wore the team uniform because he often
took to the field to play alongside his teammates.
connie-mackOver the course of baseball history,
managers gradually stopped going onto the
field to play alongside the men that they
coached.
As this happened, contrary to what you see
today, a few of them began to distance themselves
from the tradition of wearing a uniform.
Instead, they wore suits while managing.
In fact, famed manager Connie Mack wore a
business suit for each of the fifty years
that he managed the Athletics.
A former manager of the Brooklyn Dodgers,
Burt Sutton, also shunned his team’s uniform.
But this wasn’t the norm and their idea
for how a team manager should look failed
the test of time.
John Thorn, the official historian of the
MLB, has his own take on why this is the case.
“Maybe it’s just a testament to the notion
that, no matter how old you get, between your
ears you think that you’re a baseball player.”
After all, the body gets old, but so often,
particularly if those you hang around are
younger (and in this case incredibly athletic),
the mind still feels like you’re young and
vibrant as ever.
Many MLB managers also have been wearing a
baseball uniform since they were little kids,
so it may just seem more comfortable for them,
despite their expanding girths.
As for the official rules on uniforms, we
have Rule 1.11, Section a, number 1 and 3
where it states: “All players on a team
shall wear uniforms identical in color, trim
and style…
No player whose uniform does not conform to
that of his teammates shall be permitted to
participate in a game.”
The official rulebook further goes on to state
in Rule 2 that “A COACH is a team member
in uniform appointed by the manager to perform
such duties as the manager may designate,
such as but not limited to acting as base
coach…”
Also in Rule 2, “THE MANAGER is a person
appointed by the club to be responsible for
the team’s actions on the field, and to
represent the team in communications with
the umpire and the opposing team.
A player may be appointed manager.”
As you can see from this, while players and
coaches are explicitly required to wear uniforms,
there is no mention of managers specifically
needing to wear the team’s uniform, nor
will you find such a reference explicitly
stated anywhere in the rule book.
In fact, they even allude to the fact that
managers are not required to wear a uniform
in rule 3.15: “No person shall be allowed
on the playing field during a game except
players and coaches in uniform, managers,
news photographers…” mentioning that players
and coaches must be “in uniform” but putting
managers in a different category.
That said, there is one references in the
rulebook that could be interpreted as managers
being required to wear the team’s uniform,
found in Rule 2 where it states a, “BENCH
OR DUGOUT is the seating facilities reserved
for players, substitutes and other team members
in uniform when they are not actively engaged
on the playing field.”
Managers would presumably be considered “team
members” even though that is not specifically
defined in the rule book.
Since they certainly spend a lot of time in
the bench or dugout during the game, and the
team members there are explicitly required
to be in uniform (and there is no mention
of the manager being allowed in the dugout
otherwise), then it would follow that managers
should be in uniform too.
However, when defining coaches, as mentioned,
the rule book explicitly states “is a team
member.”
The manager, on the other hand, is defined
“is a person…”
So perhaps assuming managers are team members
by the official rule book definitions is not
correct.
Moving on, in rule 4.07 it also states that,
“When a manager, player, coach or trainer
is ejected from a game, he shall leave the
field immediately and take no further part
in that game.
He shall remain in the club house or change
to street clothes…” also implying the
manager should be wearing special attire while
managing, though it’s not clear from this
whether this is just supposed to adhere to
the general MLB dress code or requires the
manager to wear a uniform.
And since it’s been a long time since any
manager tried to wear something like a suit,
which certainly is within the bounds of the
MLB dress code, it’s not clear what officials
would do if a manager tried wearing that during
the game instead of a uniform as tradition
dictates.
As noted, in some instances, the rulebook
seems to go out of its way to imply the manager
is not required to wear the team’s uniform,
while in the definition of a “bench or dugout”
perhaps implying they should, hinging on whether
they are officially considered team members
by the rule book’s definitions.
Of course, a player can also be the manager
or designated such, in which case they are
required to wear a uniform, but it’s been
a few decades since the last time that happened
when Pete Rose had a stint as a player/manager
for the Reds starting in August of 1984 through
his retirement as a player in 1986.
So, in the end, as to how this all got started,
it would seem originally individuals who did
the job of managers today simply wore the
uniform because they also were players, or
at least started out that way in many cases,
and later it just became a tradition.
And baseball is, perhaps more so than any
other major sport, all about tradition and
fighting tooth and nail before changing the
way things have always been done.
After all, even the MLB Hall of Fame still
honors Abner Doubleday by displaying an oil
painting of Doubleday, despite the fact that
he had nothing to do with baseball at all
and this fact is well-known and conclusively
proven.
Two blocks from the Baseball Hall of Fame
in Cooperstown (where Doubleday was said to
have invented baseball, which is why the Hall
of Fame was put in this backwater town instead
of a place more accessible to fans), there
is also a “Doubleday Field” which annually
features various Hall of Famers and retired
MLB players playing an exhibition game there
on Father’s Day weekend.
These and many other baseball honors for a
guy whose own obituary stated he was a man
“who did not care for outdoor sports.”
This is, funny enough, the only documented
instance of him being connected to sports
in any way, despite the amazing amount of
documentation on the man’s life thanks to
the journals he kept and news reports covering
the famed General.
But, you see, tradition says he invented baseball,
so here we are.